(bells ringing)
- People assume that to
ring a bell at the church
it’s just by pulling one rope and one bell.
But our church is different.
It's not as easy as it looks.
It does feel like a dance to me.
My name is Okalena
Patricia Lekanoff Gregory,
and I play the bells at the
Holy Ascension Cathedral
here in Unalaska.
Unalaska Island is located
out in the Aleutian chain
in between the Pacific
Ocean and the Bering Sea.
The church is a very iconic place,
and wherever you go on this
island, you could see it.
I've been ringing the
bells maybe 35 years.
To ring the bells,
we go up a flight of steep stairs.
Step up onto the platform.
And then you put your right
foot on the one big bell.
Your left foot on the other big bell.
And then the smaller bells,
you twist your hands and then pull 'em.
(bells clanging)
There are only a handful of other people
that know how to ring the bells.
There is no written music.
I just have to play them
by what I was taught
from watching my dad.
My dad has been playing
the bells for 60 years.
He learned from his godfather.
I'm teaching my daughter
and then also my great-nieces.
For me to learn to ring the bells
and to pass on my dad's legacy,
I think is real important.
It's an honor, of course,
to be ringing the bells
because you're ringing it for God to hear
and for the people to hear.
And that's important to me.